Hey brian,
what's up?
How's it gotten?
Pretty good.
How are you?
Great to see.
Do you mind if I ask you 67 questions?
Yeah,
let's do it.
Cool.
Yeah.
How'd you get into work today?
Believe it or not,
I took a Lyft favorite part of the software stack.
Hmm.
Uh,
I really enjoy building front end data visualizations.
Favorite thing about working at Lyft?
I love our secret hidey holes all across the office.
What was the last project you worked on at Lyft?
Uh,
I've been managing our data warehouse migration over to hive.
my favorite professor that I never actually had this professor would be Peter
Singer.
If you could spend an evening with one famous person,
who would it be?
Someone that I've always wanted to have dinner with would be,
uh,
Nick Bostrom and I'd love to chat about Ai.
Do you play any sports?
I haven't played any sports since I used to play field hockey back in Australia.
Do you miss being a student at the University of Melbourne?
Uh,
you know,
I thought it was fine,
but I really prefer working in industry.
What music genre are you currently into?
Uh,
I listened to a lot of chill.
Slash.
Ambient.
Is there a programming language that you really like?
Really like,
um,
you know,
I work mostly in sequel and Python,
but,
uh,
I'd say python is pretty flexible.
What about a language you really don't like?
You gotta be Matlab.
He's waiting after that at uni.
How are you liking San Francisco?
San Francisco is the best city that I've ever lived in.
What's something you've built with machine learning?
Um,
I've,
uh,
what's something I've built with machine letting,
well,
I can't tell you the confidential projects,
but uh,
but I've built a,
uh,
an operations model.
What's the most beautiful thing in the world?
The most beautiful thing in the world would have to be,
um,
would have to be watching the sunrise with a friend.
Do you miss your home town?
Uh,
yeah.
I really miss my family,
but my friends all moved out to SF,
so I'm pretty lucky.
That programming language of choice for machine learning.
Definitely.
Python.
What website do you waste?
Time on?
Big Time waste is how can use last person you emailed?
Uh,
I am out of candidate who is looking for data engineering jobs.
You get an all expenses paid trip to one city.
Where do you go?
I wish that they would just pay for me to stay in San Francisco.
Honestly,
this is a pretty good spot.
Would you visit Mars?
Uh,
that depends on the price and how much of the earth technology is available on
Mars?
What is one thing that excites you?
Uh,
what is one thing that excites me?
So I'm really interested in how you can use data to improve policy decisions in
the world.
What is one thing you're afraid of?
Gosh,
irrelevance.
Best advice you've ever received.
Uh,
choose the people you surround yourself by very intentionally.
What the big misconception about you?
Uh,
I think that it's very easy for people to look like they've got it all worked
out when really they've got no idea what's going on.
What's the bravest thing you've ever done?
Probably moving out to San Francisco without a job and trying to,
trying to get established here.
It's tough.
What is one piece of advice you'd give yourself 10 years ago?
I think just keep doing what you're doing.
If you were a Pokemon,
who would it be?
A,
I would be mew because then you could learn all of the moves.
Do you have any pets?
Not.
What's something you've learned in the past month?
Oh,
I really enjoyed the neurolink article on brain computer interfaces.
What's a topic and machine learning you'd like to explore more?
Uh,
let's say a topic and machine learning.
I would really love to learn more about self driving car autonomy.
Do you think will solve intelligence in your lifetime?
I hope I live long enough to see that happen.
If you ran the world,
what is one thing that you would enact?
One law.
One law that I would enact would be listened to.
Your economists.
That was one person you looked up to when you were in college.
I'm in college.
Uh,
I guess it was Bill Gates seems to be doing some pretty impactful stuff.
What were you like as a kid in grade school?
Probably pretty weird and annoying.
What deep learning library besides tensorflow,
do you what besides the nights it's tends to play.
It's the only one.
What's something that excites you about the future?
Um,
Gosh,
uh,
just we live in like the most exciting time.
So everything about the future is,
is an open book.
What is one major unsolved research problem you'd love to see tackled?
Um,
so there was some really interesting research in the,
uh,
how to get alignment correct with Ai.
I would love to see more research there.
What's more interesting?
Generative models or discriminative models?
I think there's a lot of business problems right now that you can solve with
discriminative models.
If you could be a superhero,
who would it be?
A superhero is Ozymandias a bad answer?
What's your spirit animal?
Spirit animal would have to be a bash favorite computer scientist.
Um,
I dunno if this counts as a computer scientist,
but Richard Fineman was pretty cool.
If you had a time machine,
when would you visit?
Well,
uh,
I would love to fast forward in time and try to get to the other side of the
great filter.
Do you still use Uber
the last time?
I used to,
but it was when I was traveling internationally.
Android or iPhone.
Android.
What would surprise people about life?
That list?
I think you're just,
you've given a lot of responsibility.
Favorite Linux distro.
They boot two is pretty user friendly.
Have you ever been in love?
Yeah,
luckily enough.
What's the point of life?
Oh my God.
Um,
to,
uh,
to like to make the world a better place and to be happy.
Have you ever built an app with machine learning that you use in your day to day
life?
You know,
I haven't,
but I would really love to build a app that helps you manage your friendships
and let you know who you should be messaging when.
If you were to start from scratch today,
what is a learning resource you would use to learn machine learning?
Uh,
I would use the open science data masters,
open data science masters.
What is something you do to relax?
I drink tea with my housemates.
Awesome.
Well thanks for waiting for answering those questions and their worries.
All right.
Have a good one.